[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
où
ce chaos
vous
fait drôle de voir changer ça ici c'est
l'endroit
c'est un bel endroit pour sarah la
rosace de notre dame c'est un bon
endroit
ah oui magnifique surtout le soir c'est
vrai que t'as pas le look à chanter ça
de poids la casta diva
ouais mais tu le fait très bien j'adore
cette chanson
la classe qui l'a chanté c'est
magnifique magnifique
[Musique]
comment tu vis tout ce qui t'arrive tu
vois ça comment tu viens de loin quand
même tu vois bâgé janvier la ville de
quoi de mulhouse et colmar colmar
ouais la préfecture de colmar ouais j'ai
besoin de recul c'est vrai que c'est
émouvant
ces reines d'un jour donc les dames d'un
seul coup un producteur s'est intéressée
à toi ils ont c'est vrai que en même
temps qu'elle giardini tu découpes et
des des cadavres d'animaux c'est quoi ce
oui et ça c'était aux services
vétérinaires
j'avais travaillé 4 après balle j'étais
parti de nouveau sur colmar où il ya eu
le licenciement comme comme jardinier
voilà c'est ça moi en suisse allait
passer bien quoi mais comme il
appartient tous les étrangers qui cela
que j'ai demandé pour des veaux travail
à colmar
ils vont ils retrouver cette place mais
pourquoi on découpe les cadavres des
animaux ce sera quoi assez pour faire
des autopsies mais pourquoi va pouvoir
si c'était malade ou ce qu'ils avaient
comme l'agora sur l'a320
voilà 220 sur les animaux c'est à 1000
sur les animaux
moi c'est pas dérangeant de faire ça
vraiment pour dire au début c'était
c'était vraiment dur 1 mais à force de
savoir pourquoi ces faits c'est
intéressant très intéressant
ces volets bateau rouge magnifique
dommage tqs
tout court
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus